doch mal auf luke herzlich willkommen
wir heute meine damen und herren seiner
weiteren episode ich habe euch auf
instagram gefragt was ich in der
heutigen folge movistar planet machen
soll und die meisten von euch meinten
ich solle mir einen neuen account
erstellen mittlerweile weisheit zäher
jeder movistar blendet spieler dass ich
elefanten haben
von daher stelle ich mir heute einen
neuen account und zwar ein mädchen
thema war richtig schön hier blaue augen
bei den haaren würde ich sagen machen
wir so will
[Musik]
als benutzernamen wähle ich einfach mal
in die sap sap ist pizza rückwärts genie
ist und da sind wir jetzt auch schon auf
dem movies abblendet red carpet
angekommen hier kommt ein mädel an und
begrüßt uns auf dem roten teppich hey
jetzt sind die erste willkommen beim
movies abbau dieses umwerfen ausgang der
dankeschön dankeschön als mal ok cool
das heißt wir sind jetzt hier in der
movistar kleine feld angekommen
das hier ist unsere pace und wir
brauchen erstmal einen status suche nach
beuys herz ja das heutige ziel ist
nämlich dass wir uns jungs aufreißen und
daher gehen wir mal direkt in den chat
bereiche fordere eine ms gibt truth the
beach ok ab hin
also hier sind wirklich nur mädels am
start von daher würde ich sagen wir
gehen einen anderen raum ab ins café saß
in einem café angekommen ich stelle mich
mal direkt hier neben die tafel dann
weiß jeder direkt was abgeht hier vorne
es auf jeden fall ein junge der
highschool kids teil
wer will mit mir zusammen sein als
gedacht
cookie style ich bin die wie geht's dir
also gehen aber so langsam vor jetzt
hier in der unterhaltung wie bereits
gesagt ist meine heute unbeantwortet
wir wollen ganz langsam vorgehen weil
das ziel der heutigen episode ist ja
dass ich mir einen jungen kläre
von daher schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal
du siehst aus wie mein rechter fuß
also so wie er seinen freund kriegen
ich werde mit der pid mix bei
sonnenuntergang machen baby frei wird ja
ja was ja bist du in mich verliebt ja
geil das heutige videos innerhalb von
zwei minuten abgeschlossen weil der
coach ist sich nach nur drei nachricht
nun in mich verliebt hat er wirklich das
ganze wenig ausdenken wir machen jetzt
aber mal richtig hinterhältigen move
entwickeln wir gerade mit dem cookie
style rum ich dir jetzt allerdings rüber
zum lehr und 3 3 6 5 7 lehrern ich liebe
dich
[Musik]
die cookies sein und lehrer darauf jetzt
reagiere danke ich mich auch sich
überzeugt haha corp ok jetzt macht
dieser batgirl 0 1 0 2 3 auch noch ihre
fresse auf 0 1 0 2 3 was willst du denn
jetzt alter nichts von dir weiter die
mich schon hoch gerade 0 1 023 ich liebe
leon also halt dich von ihm fern er hat
mir einen korb gegeben aber ich liebe
dich leon einfach aus prinzip jetzt
beobachten alles klar
wenn ich geil wahnsinn bei ladis ich
glaube wir haben es uns mit allen in
diesem café hier jetzt versetzt und dann
würde ich sagen ich verlasse jetzt mal
das café und wir gehen mal an dem strand
nicht an den titel biete an diesem neuen
dienst aber nur frauen
wir suchen ja männer suchen die schotten
boys für sind die reisesuche geiles weib
4 will hat buch schreibt mir dabei
unseren kandidaten gefunden hallo ich
habe bock suche geile 24 möchte dein
freund sein
mein gott er schreibt hast du bock ich
antworte jetzt einfach mal ich hab doch
ich habe aber keine ahnung auf was er
hinaus will hast du bock bilder zu
schicken davon was dir was willst du mit
bildern von mir ohne pflanzen
dr
dadurch menschen nicht sind sämtlich
abstoßen aber gut meinte der abonnenten
ich würde an der stelle das heutige
movistar planet wie dir jetzt auch
beenden
die mission war ja dass wir uns typen
aufreißen und ich glaube das hat sehr
gut geklappt hatte schon echt crazy was
da für leute unterwegs sind auf dieser
plattform also sei auf jeden fall
vorsichtig falls ihr selber mobistar
plänen spielen sollte allerdings als ich
mein heutiges video gefallen hat das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter dem
video das schreiben in die kommentare
was eventuell in der nächsten folge mit
cindy asic machen soll und falls sie
noch kein abonnent zeit von meinem kanal
dann klickt auf abonnieren
weil kostenlos und verpasst keine videos
mehr
[Musik]